anymore here's what you need to do you
need to get yourself a copy of the 1990
Sears catalog okay oh yeah this was the
Jim this is dope this is the kind of
thing you flipped through when you
perfect before you write before you kill
yourself yeah when you as you're eating
taking all the painkillers and drinking
you just flip through the 19 take me
home so it's um look how cool we were we
were pretty cool look how cool we were
you can't hate on like you cannot hate
on
I don't want anybody to photoshop Mike
and I in this okay no don't don't last
thing we need people doing is
photoshopping Royce and I on the series
cattle I want to be an internal guy I
throw cousin Joe on there tell ya Gus
enjoy the Beetlejuice one let's go
beetle it Mike might go no Mike likes
Robocop so he'll definitely take Robocop
and I'll take Turtles let's do this
[ __ ] fly fly and Mike was just a
computer you had was it this powerful
the introducing revolution to computers
the compact IBM ps1 series one hundred
buckaroo nice right so probably on that
that computer probably only cost $3500
how much was it it should say $1,400
$1,400 or $30.00 you imagine thing
$1,400 for that alright Mike they say we
never do enough for the ladies look at
this hunk like that onesies for a minute
look at that hunk you think it out you
think it has a butt flap umm if it
doesn't I would have returned it alright
now I of course would go for the for the
for the Sony but what which which
Walkman would you take the Sears one 436
you got a girl xi4 18 yeah I mean you
got a you got a really back then you to
really carefully choose your your your
Walkmans and your tape decks because the
quality matters but then okay then again
some of them would get too expensive
this is any era where every like the
most expensive one usually wasn't
the best one yeah it was just like made
to seem fancy so the sony's out so nice
out sharps out probably go with the
Magnavox maybe the Panasonic Panasonic
Panasonic still kind of man quality look
Sony was still a [ __ ] charges so much
for the RCA if you're you know got save
a couple bucks now if you want us if you
but or if you were poor you have to get
the LX I which was eighteen bucks all
for something for the fellas we got
something for the fellas carefree
comfort why did everybody look like
Ellen while I was telling Mike affair
that they dress like what Billy eyelash
dresses like now it's pretty yeah
but you know what they look like like
there would be extras in blossoms high
school is that what Billy eyelash does
she's just like oh just get me something
from the non DC's catalog are those some
Bugle Boy jeans hell nah ho you know de
pollo listen there's nothing that says I
hate you then buying somebody assorted
meats and cheeses for Christmas no I'll
be honest with you I love this gift but
not usually like that usually when it's
a gift pack like this it's all terrible
meats in Jesus yeah from a Sears catalog
I would rather somebody get me one of
those but like like packaged by Publix
about that's probably it would be more
delicious what is this is this just a TV
yeah it's an elegant TV bro Wow with the
wood paneling really shows class this is
suck it's in deep in 2001's house oh boy
oh dude now you could say this is what
they took from us best all right I don't
know where those kids are now best
grandma on earth I need to know where
these best kid best momma I don't want
to know where that adorable young kid is
now he's probably just like a meth head
you're right in the house jesse was
shooting up and I'll be like Edward
Furlong now halt ladies get yourself a
new kids huh the block ladies if you
turn only beanbag who the [ __ ] were you
even yeah seriously uh Europe and kids
New Kids on the Block fan named all the
members
I know Ian Donnie and Danny just mark
you're just naming people from full
house now stop Uncle Jesse
[Laughter]
Oh ladies guess what you ought to get in
shape or creepy dudes have wanted a
masturbate without the [ __ ] chamber
one of our points know it's funny I
think there was always a set of these
tapes in in every woman yes family's
house yep and nine to Muslim same there
was a eight-minute abs they thought they
thought somehow that buying these tapes
was gonna force them into getting into
shape oh yeah I know I'm committed
because I bought some VHS ha's god they
were so cringe - oh no oh no these are
some cool kids these are like see these
are the kind of kids you don't want to
run in are the guys you want to run in
these guys when you're out at night
it looks like somebody miniaturized the
cast of wings Wow all dressed up for a
night off look at this tripod cast you
have a kid with the camo overalls but
he's wearing a long-sleeve shirt that
has bomber jackets on it you have been a
very spiffy looking Jay Leno number
denim top denim bottom lots of pockets
but he has like the Top Gun that gets
the Eagle patch on him and then if you
go over to the right you have a kid
wearing a sweater that I guarantee use
itchy just by looking at it and are
those camouflage jeans
does he have camouflage jeans I don't
know oh [ __ ] I don't know why all those
kids I don't know why all the kids back
then were dressed like new Jack oh [ __ ]
all the kids were dressed like the
Dudley Boyz for no reason now you know
what I want to tell my kids this was the
shield this is
Garfield phones remember how impractical
those phones were okay so I had a whole
I had an Incredible Hulk phone that
would like was like the Hulk holding up
a rock and like the rock was the phone
and yes they were they were very
impractical but none of these are
wireless come on now get what is that
phone made out of Legos Tyco I don't
remember that phone no I remember the
Garfield phone I don't remember this
this Lego phone down here I guess you
build your own phone there probably once
but if that's actually kind of cool and
I feel like I would have remembered it
or you would have remembered I don't
remember so the fact that we don't
remember it I have a feeling it was one
of those things that was just recalled
because like a couple houses burned down
and some kids died and there were like
no more with the Lego phone Beetlejuice
the cartoon ghostbusters I guess the
cartoon microwaves because is that
person cooking a [ __ ] ham and the
microwave them sometimes you gotta cook
a whole ham quick yeah now why is the
price of a microwave neither gone up or
down I mean until literally the exact
same I mean well not if you adjust for
inflation I mean you can still get a $29
microwave easily yeah easily yeah you're
right you're right um I got this for
Christmas I got a gameboy for Christmas
two of them my grandparents got one for
me and one for my brother and I had the
connection cable oh nice and we were
rockin some Tetris rock and some Tetris
yeah I had Gameboy uh that was almost
[ __ ] games uh
what was the cartoon game that was
really good
cartoon game Super Mario Land was really
good Super Mario Land was good it was
like that it was not ducktales but it
was uh it was some kind of cool game
that was I'm sure some 100 remember I oh
holy [ __ ]
I was the gym I had this I had that was
the gym right Genesis that came with
witcher's come with my came with altered
beast your skin with altered yeah there
are different ones that was different
lattice
- or so I was one of those Sonic's to
the best Sonic or Sonic 1 it was one of
those but I always a Genesis kid I
I got SNES later me - I Genesis first
what that was the first one I got and it
had some it had some [ __ ] great
earthworm jim I have a second channel
Doug yeah
Sega channel was something that we never
yeah you have it now it's just called
game paths I know the same thing yeah
you had take a channel now I was
thinking man that was not around my area
because it's a sonic something like my
parents would have gotten but then I
think it was only for Time Warner it was
on you I'm assuming up up in New York
that's what you had was Time Warner
probably no cable vision or kit maybe
cable cable they didn't have it down
here altered beast man I remember that
rise from your grave once the second
channel came out it really was the first
it was like the first hint of like
streaming game pass type [ __ ] it was
dope like and yeah a lot of games on
there sucks but dude it every month you
had at least 5 something heavy headers
and like 5 full games you wouldn't be
able to play all month like it was so
you always had all the fantasy star
games all that [ __ ] man I was a dope $20
from I to see been a fan of you guys for
a while but haven't been able to donate
hate to see what YouTube's doing to you
but truly hope that you guys can let go
of the stress and truly have a happy
Thanksgiving no no is for all you do oh
we will thank you yeah no we're gonna
let go this should we we've uh we've
actually had a really long talk behind
the scenes and we are going to kill
ourselves
so that's it'll be a great Holloway you
know cuz then you don't want to be the
one who ruined everybody's Thanksgiving
it's very selfish if you do it right in
the sweet spot in between Thanksgiving
and Christmas they can kind of get over
it during each holiday it's really great
what a mega Winnipeg at least one RT has
at least one ROTC fan at about 10,000
violent meth addicts by the way love the
obscure Simpsons references thank you we
do love Simpsons Dave Rambo I got
recently divorced chick a microwave
cooking for one book for Christmas
thanks for the laughs and that's [ __ ]
that is a brutal that is a
gift cook microwave cooking for one oh
yeah it is let's see
no one said you've made everyone says
Happy Thanksgiving guys your show makes
my days better thank you
that was from domina mortis
captain nots can't listen live due to
being away visiting family trying to
trying to tell the truth about the flat
earth when I catch a moon Moonbeam in a
magnifying glass
it feels cold cold it's cold as cold as
cold my favorite guy he's my favorite
actually he's gonna quickly not be my
favorite though like oh yeah yeah after
enough times are watching him bother
people you start to go like off shut
that leave them alone I'm sorry but
every woman ever should only wear this
that's this though Simpsons and I
carumba and a Simpsons family like I
guess these were pajamas like sleeping
should be like a nightshirt like a
nightshirt right that's what you should
call your show at night night sure nice
shirt I have an idea here's it how about
you call your show Night Court you get a
bald guy to be the bailiff to be a
magician judge yeah dude feel great you
don't want to be a magician Jets who
doesn't want to be a judge that's also
that is a highly underrated show whether
I like Night Court makes it great such a
piece of [ __ ] on some levels yeah put on
but where it counts like just being
funny and stuff it's a great show look
at this [ __ ] power couple dude you
got to get monogrammed how much is in
the monogram
it doesn't the 26 Oh nonono regular but
if you want to monogram their 50 so
their 50 27 if you don't get the monitor
there's some real and word rich stuff
right there
VI VLP oh my in case what you got you
don't know whose is whose
the lady ones not yours bro oh god
they're back okay look these kids
I see honestly I wish I could have
afforded to dress like this all the time
like the [ __ ] it's Spirit Squad yes
what do you mean the Spirit Squad no
these are uh this is like this is like
the grown up characters and sleepers but
if they were still kids
you made a sleepers right is Brad kid
grows up to be the district attorney
doesn't kid in the middle look like a
young Steve Guttenberg
it really doesn't MIDI Guttenberg it
looks like three rich young white kids
went back in time to dress themselves
you know what they look like they look
like they're they look like they're
about about to go hi Dan Crenshaw thank
you for your service hahaha
I just want to talk about the
demographic shift in America that's
right it's the creeper's ladies and
gentlemen Nick Nick err nation rising up
you know they all look like they're
going to the world's tiniest tiniest
little job interview I love it oh [ __ ]
man that was it that's a perfect way to
end this literally all now is which one
of them is Nick Fuentes I can't tell
well hi why's the one on the left yeah
the one on the right looks like Patrick
Casey this is Patrick Casey who's the
one who's a political figure in the
mirror on the government now oh [ __ ] its
Kushner middle school seriously this
brand Paul in the middle Rand Paul now
by the way Rand Paul now not even as a
kid
and then on the right that's Eric Trump
on the left that kid looks like a young
Bob Odenkirk better call baby and the
kid on the right looks like he's about
to give a greet his good speech black
leather driving gloves since the kid on
the right looks like Bradley Bradley
Cooper in limitless after he took the
pill I stopped this is dumb let's move
on all right
no wait one more thing the one on the
right is Richard Spencer yeah octa roots
I used to own these people all right
come on come buddy said the cast of the
mini cast of American Psycho I want to
get rich and then have kids so that I
could just dress my kids like that 24/7
yeah like I would be universally hated I
want my kids to be [ __ ] dressed like
they are better than all of the other
kids I like that